était blême après d'être que je peux que
je prendrais cette année comme quoi par
exemple bac anglais comme des herbes
tableau il était très bien ce livre ça
nous a fait rigoler il y avait des
peintures de picasso
il y avait des peintures que tu commets
fait oui oui
poséidon et ses îles seychelles au doré
sont plus de faire ça surprend plus pas
par exemple la tuerie à côté je vois
qu'avant ça surprend je t'aime bien ça
tu te rends compte qu'il ya plein de
styles différents par exemple en plus le
style de picasso c'est pas pareil que
les autres que picasso sais c'est un peu
bizarroïdes
il ya beaucoup d'oeuvres de danseuses
et puis l'artiste
vol d'idée de sortir pour voir refuser
c'est comme chien raconte l histoire de
du peintre et puis parfois c'était
rigolo
donc ça tape le oui l'a jour un peu
toute la mythologie aussi des fois ça
peut être rigolo
et puis des fois il ya des mystères
pourquoi mona lisa par exemple elle est
aussi populaire différents
est ce que ces textes sont donc de
signer
puisque
c'est burgaud